get destroyed and now these kids got the
tick tock like smack your teacher
challenge what yes
yes what what body face
you should have guns teachers should
have guns yeah i'm okay with teacher
challenge i'm okay i'm definitely okay
with armament teachers but after we
watched the tick tock challenge and
there was like there was a teacher that
came out she was like uh oh don't try
that in my class i'll beat you i like
this i like this energy
okay what's this guy right here what's
going on how many views you got all
right you gotta look like you guys
laughed a little bit he's gotta get
smacked
slap a teacher al's the worst of
googling bro yeah i know we're gonna
give you the ox
we need we really need to give
mark the ox during the pot cause we're
gonna be sitting here a while disabled
teacher 64 is hospitalized
after
yeah these young kids are wild
okay
yeah don't worry i i've seen the
craziest fights in schools growing up
i ain't never seen a [ __ ] somebody
put their hands on a teacher
oh [ __ ] multiple times also why do they
call it a challenge that's just it's a
salt right yeah that's a salt but if you
put challenge behind it kind of it's
it's fine that's like a beast that's a
rap beat that's right if i get viral bro
yeah exactly there used to be that game
called the knockout challenge yeah i was
walking around with a motorcycle helmet
on during that
i was not trying to catch myself on the
floor the flies over each driver
um to this day i do have that fear i
walk around thinking [ __ ] but
it might punch me in the face yeah
because you [ __ ] on portland like that
i've never felt safer in my life yeah
about those folks just challenging them
what about what if the antifa challenge
comes
in you don't get it andrew schultz
challenge
i'll walk around portland ready to go
i'm strapped in portland and you know
guns are legal out there are they i
don't know
they're illegal when i'm out there ow we
coming through strapped or what are we
[Laughter]
uh okay but listen there was something
crazy that went down this is uh this is
teaching nowadays do you have that video
alex which video
[Laughter]
god for [ __ ] dancing
do meth you end up at netflix
it's crazy netflix is super lit that's
why they got so many specials
i need more anymore
okay look at this girl she's teaching
math this is california teacher she's
been placed on leave this is california
it's not florida i know everybody's
going to jump to the conclusion as
florida isn't there yeah florida would
never do this we need some volume
florida has a lot of native americans we
have a lot of respect for the native
people yeah
yo come on ricky
ricky come
she got the jellies on
yo is that maria bamford
[ __ ] joke like that's crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
so man
people stayed inside for a year and it
really [ __ ] them up yeah like people
really i noticed that when we got back
to stand up okay right away i noticed i
was like oh people haven't been outside
they don't know how to be in public
people just getting way too drunk not
just the social norms were gone yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's that that woman just sat inside
yeah she was dressed like that at home
to be honest
[Laughter]
do you think those kids are ever going
to forget silica toilet no i'll never
forget no do you know what sohcahtoa is
these are like the three main elements
lewis and clark
yeah
oh i got the sine cosine
tangent thank you okay
sohcahtoa is how you remember them so
what is it like opposite and hypothesis
opposite adjacent oh yeah i do remember
that yeah yeah
but now you'll really remember it
okay and sohcahtoa does sound like a
native american name can we just be
honest if i was native american i met
you and you were like hey my name's
ricky and i was like hi my name is
sokatoa would you go there's no way
that's your real name or would you oh
that makes sense you're native american
that sounds like well you don't look
native american what does that mean mark
yeah what does that mean because i don't
have a [ __ ] feather in my hat
because i'm not wearing face paint you
don't like indigenous native american
for a minute you are good
no no we're not we're we're from uh i
did the 23andme i spit in the thing okay
and uh we uh believe that you actually
believe it yeah yo they'll be making
that [ __ ] up
are you telling me i'm not sub-saharan
african
because that was in there
five percent no way yep and then uh
portuguese sun get up that's how they
get white people don't believe it they
tell them they're a little black and
they're like yes
that's all that test is is how am i not
white yeah that's the only and that's
why black people you you took the test
yeah i did but for what
like you know where you're from no no i
don't he really doesn't like literally
he really just really does it you could
guess
what part of the world
[Laughter]
no but like you know like when they say
where like white people are from they
give you the region but they don't
really know if you're from [ __ ]
scotland they'd just be saying [ __ ] i do
believe that why why what
how the [ __ ] they know you from scotland
scottish people you know scotland
they're from ireland then they walked
over i think they'd be making they found
one
andrew's teeth and it was him that's not
brian ladies
one conversation what are you saying i'm
saying just because they got the teeth
and they can identify who you are
doesn't mean they can identify your
whole genealogy so are you saying brian
landrieu's out there just with no teeth
right now i'm saying
they can't be still on the run with no
teeth i'm saying they know brian landry
is dead but they don't have a genius way
to do it just take out your teeth
take care of your teeth put them
somewhere they find the teeth they think
you're dead and then you're still alive
brian landry's free you think they just
found his teeth brian you think his
teeth
in a desert and that's it maybe some
clothing some chicken bones probably
yeah it just found some teeth you look
and get the teeth you believe what you
want what else did they find they find a
foot they haven't told us yet have they
i thought they they told us about the
teeth obviously it's unfortunate they
actually were talking about it yeah what
they say
what did they say really happened but
the truth yes how did he kill his girl
did that that's the truth
i like how that has to be a question
well the truth is not true
i don't think you're gonna handle the
truth yeah yeah yeah
calm down bro you need to calm the [ __ ]
down okay yeah
alex jones too much
no 23andme [ __ ] yo they just want
your all your information they can get
and then they just send you back some
[ __ ] oh yeah you're a four percent
[ __ ] congolese but what is that
you're literally doing it for the four
percent because you know what you are
95. yeah
you're white
and i'm a puerto rican i'm a little
curious like but you knew that before
you spit into the cup
nah but i'm not
your dad is they're saying we're
portuguese
and the portuguese people when we went
over to we went over to puerto rico you
know
got some mommies
grabbed a little made a baby that's all
it is
so you native american dog you might be
native american they say i'm not i
thought i was because i was really going
to try to get that tax oh you got to bro
they don't pay any tax at all native
americans don't correct yeah that's why
elizabeth wants to tax everybody else
because she can't tax herself yeah
do you think
that uh elizabeth warren is native
american when you met her did you feel
any spirits or anything i did i felt
that
she did i felt it what did you feel
nothing bro i didn't see her
i thought you said you just did it with
uh no i said she was actually we did
seth together that's what i said don't
put words in mind no no no no you said
that [ __ ] calling up so unemployment
white devils though we happen to be on
the same episode of late night with seth
myers no real
gifts i was [ __ ] up the way they said
you said you were hanging out with
elizabeth warren i did not you literally
said you both said i didn't be cool
you said you used every part of the
buffalo before you did seth meyer
you both said you did that okay stop it
don't lie to me okay we've been through
too much